now judy have to start with you I don't
know if Ally if you know how do you
what's the proper way to address your is
it Dame Judi Judi just do days anyone
call you Dame Judi no sometimes here
they call me Dame Dame John Gielgud said
to me he said them do these very kind
they call you you said you good oh did
you now me no Ally when you met Judy
like what were the proper way most rated
himself
I just went down it's like world your is
literally like them is if there's my
little family making a fool of myself
what do you think for you guys what do
you think the connection was between
Victoria afterward
why do you think that happened humor
well yes humor indeed but I just can
identify very easily not with of course
the responsibilities that Queen Victoria
had but I can identify very clearly with
being in your 80s your husband dying and
suddenly many of your friends dying and
and seven of my friends this year have
died and and plus my brother
she's the end of my my kind of grown-up
family ahead of me and somebody said to
me I was a yes but you do you have to
expect that you're in your 80s well if
you have that and you also don't have
many actual people you call your friends
I'm sure there were people who would
like to have been friends with her but I
didn't think she encouraged it much and
didn't encourage any relationship with
her children so you know just suddenly
suddenly somebody walks into her life
and is it and becomes everything to her
good reason a reason to get out yeah
what will it be for you for the
connection well he was he saw through
all that he saw through the royalty you
know any saw her behind all that all the
boredom and the loneliness and this
royal cage that she was this is lovely
scene you know where he he points to a
bird on the in the carpet this is a bird
of freedom you know and it's that moment
where the freedom means so much at that
point that they they complemented each
other in so many ways and they could
talk and that's the one thing they
wanted to do people didn't like that
Judy you're saying an interview I love
what you said to the Guardian about
growing older yeah still having lust and
desire George Clooney 56 years old all
of a sudden he's saying he's too old to
be in romantic comedies get the girl so
no one seemed act at 56 no more get the
girl in a rom-com so what do you say to
that he had 56 Sam I think he's wet able
to take care of himself and the last
question about playing these characters
both these characters do you have a
better appreciation of the royal family
or anyone who's in like a royal status
of the life that they have to live like
your character talks about kind of the
isolation of being royalty do you feel a
better connection to that now well I I
just have a great great admiration for
them you know they didn't choose to be
in this position to but to be in it to
be with the weight of that
responsibility and having you know
spotlight on you all the time so
everything you do and that all your days
are planned and set out Michael I
couldn't do that I couldn't do that at
all well you know it wasn't a very
pretty picture on the Indian side and so
there are so many reasons to not like
you know the Royal side um but yet there
was this wonderful
you know just because of this
relationship you see that they're real
people you know and it's thrust upon you
and you can't help it you're stuck
because it's generations and generations
of protocol
you know rules that you're following and
you have to and you have to take the
abuse you have to take the flag for it
congratulations on the story really
great well thank you very much